wow doesn't that look good just be
careful because it's it's yeah hey
nothing is is screwed down yes okay guys
so walk in the middle yeah walk in the
middle okay I just want to look at it
wow
Jackson you got your very own bridge I'm
glad you put
put big heavy beams
so the tractor can go right across it
huh
I've been working on this bridge for a
while now and I'm excited that it's
almost done
being able to show a project that I've
done on my own property by myself
um I know he's into Bridges and he's
done a lot of bridge builds himself over
the years so I know he's like interested
in something like this this is super
nice when that water's flowing this
bridge is going to be the bomb exact in
this scenario uh feeling the
satisfaction of owning a project I'm
happy that Zach's developing his own
memories that remind me a lot of the
memories that he had as a kid I think
he's replaying them out say hi he's a
little grumpy are you grumpy today oh
you
no hey hey did you remember me I don't
know your eyes open
hi little cute guy can you smile for
Grandpa hi oh he's giving me a little
smile I know oh how is he interacting
good with the brothers and sisters he's
obsessed with them especially Jackson
let me hold him for one second how heavy
is he see more than I can handle
think so
he's pretty strong he's stronger than
like I think Jackson he looks strong hey
can you smile I did that yeah see look
at you just look huge right now are you
just chilling
yeah we just needed you to come over we
needed Grandpa to be here so we weren't
so grumpy yet
that's what it was
you're just staring at you yeah he knows
mom he knows mom and dad and Jackson
Lila he's a little more like are you
gonna come at me or like he loves her
but oh that'll change he's a little like
who were you coming at me from look at
that little Josiah are you a little
chunker dude Josiah is starting to get
very alert and he's becoming like a
little human and he's um he's just
healthy and looks you know he just looks
like he's ready to take on the world
I think he's going to give Jackson a run
for his money
[Music]